I wonder if I could just squeeze one out  did Zach you that oh no he has  headphones on good I'm totally getting  away with this oh no oh god it's bad why  did I eat that breakfast burrito  maybe if I look like I don't care you  know just working nothing to see here  maybe if I swivel back and forth I'll  get the air circulating and like fan it  away okay it's working the Fanning works  now no one will ever know again  okay who did it  it smells like garbage in here come on  just admit it  this smells like boy I know right  someone's don't off are you like Fanning  it this way or something because it's  like very concentrated like just right  here  gosh that is thick very rich gas